Congratulations on building your new,
robust Mad Libs generator.
Now, if there are other words you want
to prompt our user to fill in the blanks
for, all we need to do is add the word
to our list parts_of_speech, and
our Mad Libs generator
will work as expected.
However, there's one last step that
we need to take in order to build
the Mad Libs generator you saw Andy and
I play in the beginning of stage two.
Which is to replace the words that are
found in parts_of_speech with user input
rather than the word corgi.
Now, like I said, we'll just have
to add one line of code to do this,
which we'll do by using
a function called raw_input.
Here's an example of
the raw_input function.
If we were to run this line of code,
we would be prompted with the message,
Type in a word.
If I follow those directions by typing
in let's say Udacity and then press
Enter on my keyboard, user_input will
now be set to the string Udacity.
Simple enough.
So the string you put in parentheses
is the prompt the user or
player will receive.
And whatever they type on their
keyboard, followed by Enter,
will be the variable's value.
We use raw_input in our Mad Libs
generator by prompting a user for
the part of speech we want
them to fill in the blank for.
And use that as a replacement
instead of corgi.
But where in our code do we use this?
So if this was the part of my code that
replaces the part of speech with corgi,
which you built in the last quiz,
my code will now look like this.
By adding this line of code and
by swapping the string corgi
with user_input, we now have a fully
functioning Mad Libs generator.
In the download section there will be
a file that contains all the code you've
written up until now,
including this added line of raw_input.
I've added a few strings near the top of
the file that you can play around with,
but I encourage you to write your
own Mad Libs sentences, add your
own words to the parts_of_speech list,
and run your Mad Libs generator on them.
The following videos will step you
through the process of running this
program locally so you can play
Mad Libs with your friends and family.